The tube I have has some loose crystals that are moving around. Is this something that needs to be
fixed? So the crystal hammer bulbs are those crystals are adhesed on with some type of glue
adhesive and know they do as they as it bounces around in there. Things will break off and that is
just that is not something that could be repaired. Now remember, prior to their
being any existence of the crystal hammer bulb, there's a lot of people that may be listening to
this call. They're like what is this person talking about? I don't have crystals on my tube.
That's more of a recent addition with the rife technology is with the tubes to have them sprayed
crystal sprayed on them. It gives some advantages. I've talked to another video of some advantages
of using a crystal bulb versus a non crystal bulb. So but the negative is you're going to get little
pieces that break off and there's nothing to do. So there's nothing harmful about that. It is
it's not everybody. So there's nothing to be done about that. Also, sometimes during a program,
the tube gets very hot. Is that normal? Yes, it is. So at different frequencies, the tube is going
to get hotter. That's why at different nights, you'll go, oh, the tube wasn't even hot tonight.
And at other nights that you're running it, it gets really hot. That is normal. Just try to cool it
off by maybe removing it from the covers. There's times with me, I know that if it kind of gets stuck
underneath my side and I fall asleep with it in a certain position, because there's less air flow
around the tube, it gets hotter. So there's different reasons why it gets hotter. But big part is
the frequencies that are running at a particular time that is normal and there should be anything to
worry about with that.